[موسيقى]
لديك يديك لا بأس أيها الشباب نعم إذا
جميل كالبندورة مستقبال مني
جلبت هناك حلفاء مثل ما عدا أنا مضطر إلى ذلك
أخبرك بشيء واحد لديك بعض
عيوب تتكاثر الأصدقاء
آمل لقطات تلمسني في كثير من الأحيان
لا شيء إلا أنني انضممت إلى المباراة
الأحد العرب مثل الشيخ ولد ابراهيم
bouchelagem مثل أهداف سخيفة
المدرب هو المعيار المفضل
مريض وجواد عاد بطموحاته
المجلات
انها بالفعل قليلا جدا الكمال
الزومبي عليهم في الجزائر ولكن
حذرني أعتقد أنك أكثر من اللازم
مثالي
بالمناسبة إذا أعطيت هذا المكان
من السهل تغيير الأشياء
مجرد المفاجئة أصابعك الحصول على هذا
هل سيجعله يتوقف عند التوقف
هيا لن يكون الأمر سهلاً
تغيير الأشياء يمكنني المناخ
حار ورطب ومنجم oualich عشرة
استيقاظ البحارة هوس الكراك
خائف جدا يعهد الفتحة
يستقر في الحماس الداخلي ل
هذه الطاقة
اليكس دي ماريا لكن موشكيلتنا على الساحة
حسنًا ، نحن مشكلة يجب حلها
ثم إذا أردنا تغيير الأشياء
بعد كل شيء نحن مجرد تجسد
من التغيير الذي لديك بنفسك
أثار
هيا هاجمت datar bitar & day a
قال مارك الملقب الأحد تشي التكنولوجيا
آسف ، لقد انتهى الأمر به بصرف النظر عن هذا
فندق هجين الأنف وبالمناسبة أنا في
العمر عندما يبدأ المرء بالمرور على الجانب
ظلام القوة
الآن أحاول
العيش معًا مارك في سعيدة صنع في ليل ذلك
كل ليبيا التي تلعب هناك لا تملكك
شديد التعقيد أحاول
يكتشف
وهذا التعايش في الواقع رحيل
السد الرائع مصنوع أنا
لاحظت في كل مرة قمت فيها بالهجوم
فيلم تكيف تريبالاتها
ابدأ بالفزع افعل ذلك المتأنق
طازجة ممتلئة تمامًا
إتقان التكنولوجيا أمر جيد
في بشرته يريد تغيير العالم
بالضبط
للأسف هم أن عالمه ينهار
أن تضيع إن لم تكن الموانئ
و انتوني كليموت صارخ حولها
يمكن أن تنهار أفريكارابيا إلى واحدة
الثانية
وهناك أشعر أنها خائفة وأعتقد
أن هذا الخوف أمر طبيعي لأن
حد تادين في الواقع ي-مارك مثل بشدة
تارب أكرا وأعتقد أن العالم لديه
عملت مثل هذا طوال الوقت
قالت لي المسك الريح
[موسيقى]
تسليط الضوء إلى جانب يعرف أين
الحكام
باشير في نهر اللؤلؤ ملزمون
لطيفة أو المباني المنفذة داخليًا
بينما في الشرق لا يوجد
لم يفعلوا قط عكازي اليوم
تذمر ouallal يؤدي موهبة برشلونة و
وضعنا عملية تضمن
مجرد استمرارية بين
أجيال ومن يريحنا و
أنهم نسوا الحرب بين
أجيال هذه الفكرة عقدتها صديقي
لا أعرف ما إذا كان موجودًا هنا اليوم
يحمل صندوق تطوير اللعبة
الفيديو وإجراء الاختبار و
jboss خطيرة حتى ماريو كان ألمانيا
ياسين وهم يشاهدونهم وهم يتدربون
لاستخدام ألعاب الفيديو لديهم
سوف تكون المتقدمة في هذا الكون
الأمة المرجعية وأجد ذلك
غير عادى
إنه عالم مندمج تمامًا
عملية العجول
سيون ليس لديهم مشكلة في ذلك
قل لي لماذا لا يجب على العالم
العمل كما كان لدي
كولتينيد قصوى مفصل التنقيط
norauto وأثناء شرق شمال شرق
niamey المضحك على هذا المستوى هو رئيسي
في مختبر الصوت ألتو يذكر أن أ
طريق نابالم
في هذا المستوى أدين بالكثير لوالدي
حتى لو في ذلك الوقت بالنسبة للفعلي
التدريب أو القماش المشمع
ثم لديه شخصية قاسية محطمة في
ركوب على قيم السيارة
نكص من ناحية أخرى سعيد لوقف بلدي
فخر فريق trg الإبداعي هو
حفيد ابهيشيك ثقوب كنت
خالية من اختياراتي التي
سوف يضاف داني فخور سعيدا أن
العلامة التجارية جيب جيدة يعني أنا
أضع الأهداف على العملاق
masnick j يعني أنه ينبغي علاوة على ذلك الأهداف
erding هو كذا وكذا شيء
لا تهتم ولماذا لا
في أعماقي ، على الرغم من أنني لم أملك شيئًا ، فهو
من أجلك أنك تفعل ذلك فأنت لا ترى شيئًا
أعتقد أنهم لم يهتموا بي
حتى اليوم عندما تكون في ظهر أحمر وتناسبهم
اختيار كلمة توقفنا في
فنانو الجرافيتي الشباب الليلة أردت
اجعل تجربتي الخاصة
تجربة الاستقلال وهناك لدي
واجهت أول عطل عالي الجهد
رواندا تصنع ردود أفعال فقط في الحياة
من المدرسة
بل تحطمت وحمايتها من الأمواج
دموع الكرامة عادل
مستحيل ولم تتكيف معه أبدًا
إتقانه للشباب من الطوب
حرب المال الخالق المستحيل
ثعبان في متجر مزدوج لمضاعفة
أو سترى الكثير من المشاكل
كان رد فعل شخص واحد بخلاف ذلك
كان والدي لم يقل أي شيء
شاطئ نالجا القذافي الذي أنا
اجترار وتفشل كنت مكتئبة و
كنت أشعر بالخجل قليلاً في الواقع بسبب ذلك
الجميع يضربونني في النهاية
جيمي ليوارد لأنه كان هناك جدول زمني
لديك مدونة سلوك حقيقية
كانت أول هدية قدمها لي
عرض حياته عليه وفهم ذلك
لم أكن بحاجة لتغيير خياري
أنه كان خياري وأنه كان عليّ ذلك
تواصل هناك
لقد فهم أنه ليس مضطرًا لذلك
يتدخل وقد فهم ذلك أيضًا
نصف نجاحهم لم أحققه حقًا
أحتاجه حيث أحتاج
كان خلال فشلي
كنت بحاجة إلى ipj iris ولا في
كياني الصغار والشباب كما أعطيت
والاهتمامات وهناك أقدر أن لدي
محظوظ
جيد إلا أن هناك الناس فيه علينا
فهم ذلك ولكن فقط نسيانهم
يجب أن يأتي سريرهم منا أيضًا
العنابي في مجالات طريقتنا
قال ماو حقا تغيرت وظيفة
جعل حوليات الرجل وهذا الهوس
رياك والمخابز نير بلو لا
من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى الخلافات كما لو
كان واضحا قال قدري ل
أحجار الرحى غنية ورائعة التغيير
التي نريد تحفيزها بدون أي
المقاومة أو العالم هذا العام أو
نفس نفس الذي يختلط أولاً مع
مارلين اذهب للتعرف على الخط
هو التغيير
علينا أن نفترض أنه علينا الانتقال إلى
لا ينبغي توقع إجراء من الآخرين
ما يجب علينا أن ننخرط فيه
وهناك كانت لدي تجربة
مؤخرا خلال مؤتمر بلدي
حفلة سلمان حمد آب لي مع
قادة الحزب الشباب وقررنا
لإنشاء أثناء الجري خلال هذا المؤتمر
تيار يدعو إلى مشروع جديد
طريقة جديدة لصنع
طريقة جديدة لإدارة الحزب
وهناك قررت أنني سأذهب
يقدم
أعددنا كل شيء مدرب وكل شيء كان فيه
ضع كل شيء وكل شيء كان في الرأس
واضح ونظيف
الإستراتيجية رؤية إستراتيجية
وسائل الإعلام موقع التواصل
كان الفريق بأكمله في مكانه
وفي العالم لا أعرف لماذا نمتلكها
أردنا المزيد وبدأنا في المشاهدة
حولنا ويدينون هناك
يذهب الرجال فقط باريت لهم
سيارات السيدان أو شارع العمود أليزي المضي قدما
إنه جيد ولكنه لم يأت و
سوف يغسل كل واحد بدأ الشك
تحدث أكثر وقررنا المغادرة
ليقع او يسقط
لقد أسقطت ليون وأنا نادم
لأن أعصاب الطاقة ذلك
كان لدي في ذلك الوقت كان كذلك
قوية أن ما أخاطر به و
أخيرًا في أحسن الأحوال فزت في أسوأ الأحوال
كنت أعيش تجربة لماذا لدي
أسقطته علمتني الأشياء
فعل هذا علمني أن أجمع في
الحياة يجب على المرء أن يكون على علم به
القدره
ناركودولار كولماري كونان
قدرات الرجال على التصرف أو نحن
اذهب إلى rafour 1 وعلينا استكشافها
ثم نذهب إلى جنون مانديرا هذا
أن لدينا كل ما أعرفه الآن
بفضله وصل j إلى الحساب ne
المعدة هناك يجب أن نشعر بها تقفز
الحقائق الميتة التي تجمعها الدول
وحالات التهجير وبعد ذلك
أخيرًا بين البداية هو هدف
الطريق لاتخاذ
لكن الأشرطة المختلطة حيث ألقت ابنتها
في مجموع mnu في كل خطوة يخطئ
ربما على طول الطريق
اكتشف طموحات جديدة
قدرات جديدة سيكون من السخف
يمر بجانب
إذا كان علي أن أقول شيئًا واحدًا فهو ذلك
لا تخف من أن تعيش التغيير
هو كيف اوجير المستوطنين توماس التحرير لك
هي الصفقة الجديدة ثم هذه المياه
ترتفع للتكيف معك وليس
العكس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]